welcome back career criminals continue
their abuse as Democrats keep turning
them loose and they won't take the blame
for releasing Thugs who rob kill and
maim
yes it's the most mind-blowing statistic
since that year I dated all the Osmonds
in New York just 10 criminals were
responsible for nearly 500 crimes in
less than a thousand days and all of
those crimes were at my local Walgreens
it took them weeks to restock my
ointment
boy they don't like that joke at all
anyway that's according to NYPD stats
obtained by the New York Post which is
owned by our parent company Radio Shack
it's all happened since 2020's bail
reform which stripped judges from
setting bail on nearly all misdemeanors
and non-violent felonies the result 10
perps 500 arrests less than three years
they're making a bigger mockery of Law
and Order than the casting of iced tea
like that was funny I'd never like him
playing a cop what say you mayor Adams
is our Criminal Justice System insane
our criminal justice system is insane
time and time again our police officers
make an arrest and then the person
who is arrested for assault felonious
assaults robberies and gun possessions
they're finding themselves back on the
street within days if not hours after
arrest now many of those repeat arrests
were for thefts but it's sad when the
good news is only thousands of thefts
what a relief but Adams also dropped
this Whopper of a stat on gun crime this
year
2
386 people were arrested with a gun of
those approximately
1921 are out on the street gun arrests
in custody
19.5 percent
out of custody over 80 percent I gotta
do something about it you literally have
to shoot someone to go to jail
so whose fault is this surely the
lawmakers bear some responsibility am I
right well New York Governor Kathy hokel
is passing the buck so fast she tore her
rotator cuff well we gave judges was the
ability to consider severity of the
offense is this a repeat offense
is it a is there a history involved here
I believe in accountability at all
levels and you know people can't just be
saying that they don't have something
when they do have it to make that as an
excuse God what an idiot account
accountability at all levels I wish that
she'd lose her job faster than a porn
star with monkey pox
anybody can get it here's an idea how
about just repealing bail reform instead
you knucklehead or at least start
appointing Warlords right hell if we're
not going to lock them up we should just
give them an award
welcome back to the prime time thuggies
and now for the final Award of the
evening
[Applause]
[Music]
and here are the nominees for New York's
best new Criminal
Jimmy two toes 88 arrests failure to
appear in court 14 times and robbing a
Footlocker managed by his own father
Frankie the spike mugging every single
customer at his local Denny's then
refusing to leave the scene before
finishing his Grand Slam and last Gary
grand larceny Davis stealing 39 flat
screen TVs from Best Buy and reselling
them in their parking lot
and the winner is
Frankie the spike Frankie could not be
here today because he's out robbing that
Denny's again here to accept the award
on his behalf is his lawyer
thank you my client has prepared a
speech I'd like to share
all right thank you so much that's all
the time we have we want to thank our
sponsor the New York state judicial
system for doing absolutely nothing to
stop these people thank you good night
tires I don't even like doing crime
segments anymore because I feel like we
don't have anything to say about it
except the ugly realities do you have
anything Solutions thoughts things to
raise our Spirits uh these stats I they
mean absolutely nothing there's so
there's 10 guys doing how many guys are
not getting arrested okay there's a lot
more than that we just had an
Administration that made sure they got
86 000 new tax cops right I think we
could use a quarter of that I'm just in
the streets here like it's it's
laughable when you got to be careful
when you hear stuff like this because I
used to hear this a lot in the kid in my
neighborhood there's only a few of them
it would be so easy to round them up so
we don't have to change anything we just
got to get those 10 off the streets and
everything will be great guys it's only
700 people in the whole city huh is that
what it is is that why my house gets
robbed every week and you can't go on
the streets neighborhood it's it's
complete we can't fall for that this is
another one of the progressive moves to
give us stats because if they really
cared you're the governor why are you
not fire the D.A right right that's in
the mirror why are you not doing an
emergency to getting you could get
troops in the state you could do things
if you really wanted to giving us stats
and tricking us into thinking that I
mean because there will be people
watching that going it's just 10 people
well just lock those guys up and yeah oh
my God this is great yeah yeah and
there'll be 10 more people they have no
idea right Ellis uh you just moved to
the east coast not in the city smart
move uh what are your thoughts my
thoughts are you know I'm from England
we don't have crime though we're very uh
no
a joke I joke uh look it looks to me
like the governor's blaming the judges
that's what I hear and then and then the
mayor is blaming the governor and
everyone's blaming everyone else and it
seems like this has been going on for a
a long long long time why does it take
to your point why does it take so long
to repeal yeah um and and do something
about the crime but I think this is a
symptom of what happens when you defund
the police and you have these movements
in San Francisco and New York and
Minnesota and you look at the rising
crime blah blah blah blah blah you know
something has to happen people want to
feel a bit safe have you bought a gun
yet uh I have not oh you'll love it
really yeah yeah I'll go gun shopping
with you where does one go gun shopping
oh I could show you some places okay
yeah Mike Baker's basement yeah Mike's
busy he's going to be taking the uh the
audience away for an afternoon exactly
everybody gets a gun too yeah ah
the only problem is there's usually like
a severed finger still in the trigger
cat what are your thoughts here yeah the
thing that really makes me upset is the
gun thing the people you're gonna call
it you know illegal guns on the streets
and they're going back out and the
people that are allowing this to happen
are the same people are saying we need
to go after legal gun owners who
lawfully would like to own a gun and
demonizing that in those people that is
something that really really pisses me
off because it couldn't be less
obviously completely disingenuous uh but
it has real effects on people's ability
to keep themselves safe no it's true
it's true you have to jump through so
many Hoops to get a gun and you could be
in but yet I should just buy them on the
street Mike like everybody else does and
they say the fact that I would like to
have a gun that I'm a bad person for
that yeah exactly for wanting a
puncher's chance exactly yeah I'm
extremely murderable yes that's true I
pride
you know Baker uh how is this crime wave
going to end
uh well it won't until there's
consequences for for a crime and look
they've got all sorts of of uh case
studies and nobody wants to talk about
it that shows that jail time actually
you know resolves recidivism you know it
actually does work it you know you want
to be smart about it but until there's
consequences uh you know this is not
going to change uh but also I think an
important point is I'm really surprised
your ointment joke didn't get more of a
response you know it's interesting I I'm
we're going to be doing some test runs
on new ointment jokes but something it
runs hot and cold sometimes you'll get
an audience that that's all they want
are women just yeah and they'll they
won't laugh at anything else and then
you have Pro poop jokes yeah audiences
they get they get so upset if they're no
poop jokes but then if I have too many
poop jokes so it's like a lot of the
bodily function ointment jokes are are
it's a complex issue it is complex it's
layered and I also I mean I always
thought ointment was one of those three
words that I thought you could never you
failed to get a laugh ointment uh moist
it's just fun to say yeah uh and and fun
to be and um uh did I say no you can't
think of it
hockey [ __ ] hockey [ __ ] another one try
saying hockey puck everybody
hey this is he's legit this bastard's
evil
what is he what have you what did these
people do to you Baker I'm just asking
did you were you up really early I was
up really early
can always tell people around very early
and it's always the guest in that chair
yeah they're like oh I did three shows
today
shut up this is more important Mike
Baker all right up next these two prove
life is Pleasant unless you're a peasant
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else